it was one of the defining moments in
world war ii a mission that turned the
tide of history
the doo little raiders were the first
pilots to successfully strike japan
following the japanese attack on pearl
harbor the raid has been well documented
but the story of what happened after has
not been told in full
until now both the raid and the little
known history that followed are covered
in michelle
paradis new book last mission to tokyo
it was seen as miraculous you know the
united states had been losing the war
up to that point and the doolittle raid
was the first
moment when americans really thought not
only
should we win this war we can win this
war just
four months earlier the japanese attack
on pearl harbor
pulled america into world war ii i asked
that the congress declare a state
of war has existed between the united
states
and the japanese empire but it also told
us
the u.s did not at the time have the
technical prowess to win
because american fighter planes could
not reach japan
this is really a book in two parts yeah
michelle
parody is the author of the new book
last mission to tokyo
a combination epic war story and high
stakes courtroom drama
we met him at the american air power
museum in farmingdale new york
april 1942 that's a dark period of world
war ii
uh we'd lost the philippines the baton
death march results in ten thousand
american soldiers dying
tens of thousands more being interned by
the japanese the british lose shanghai
singapore all of their major possessions
americans did not have a way to win
in the pacific until a pioneering pilot
named
jimmy doolittle was put in charge of a
top secret raid that many considered
a suicide mission not until they are
miles at sea to these men
know definitely the mission for which
they have volunteered
his charge was to get 16 b-25
bombers from the deck of the u.s
aircraft carrier hornet
into the heart of japan to strike tokyo
so they basically rip out everything
inside the plane that doesn't
require it to get into the air they take
out all the guns except for that front
gun
uh they take out all the safety
equipment
and they fill it with gasoline they
basically put these giant gas tanks
throughout the plane so they could have
these flying gas cans
with four bombs in them get their way
over tokyo and onto japan
originally planning to fly 400 miles on
the day of the mission
the hornet spotted an enemy patrol boat
fearing they'd be discovered the u.s
moved up the attack by 10 hours
and they launched from 650 miles off the
coast of japan
it's airborne the first army bomber ever
to be launched from a carrier
is safely in the air with no fuel for
the ride back
the raiders were eventually forced to
parachute out and let their planes crash
land but their bombs did reach their
targets
later in china the flyers who bailed out
safely
are decorated by madam chiang kai-shek
the doolittle raid
pushed japan back on its heels it turned
it from a country that thought it was
going to win the more
and was making the kind of decisions a
winner makes to win
and moved it to an entirely defensive
strategy that ultimately made
the it completely literally changed the
tide
following the raid japan made a series
of strategically
disastrous decisions culminating in the
battle of midway
a stunning american victory but as all
that happened
the fate of some of the doolittle
raiders remained in question
80 men were on the mission 77 survived
but
eight were captured while in japanese
prisons
they were accused of murdering civilians
tortured
and three of the doolittle raiders were
executed following a short
show trial a fourth died of starvation
and malnutrition
the survivors were left with lifelong
physical and mental scars
they tortured americans they murdered
americans they starved them to death and
imprisoned them in solitary confinement
driving them half mad
parade who's also a lawyer for the
defense department and has defended
guantanamo detainees
says this book is the first in-depth
recounting of the trial of the japanese
soldiers responsible
which took place in shanghai after the
war in 1946
the thing that really grabbed me and
made me want to invest in this story
when i first started researching it was
that we gave the japanese a fair trial
the book includes new details about the
prosecution's investigation
deep into the fog of war to find the
perpetrators of a crime against
america's greatest heroes
and the stories of those tasked with
defending the accused
a role that put them in the crosshairs
of public opinion while trying to uphold
american ideals that includes the lead
defense lawyer colonel edmund bodeen
a pilot himself here he's representing
someone who is hated
by everyone in the country who everyone
assumes is just going to be executed so
they assume he has an impossible mission
too
and nevertheless he commits to doing it
the right way there was pressure to not
do it that way
absolutely there was a lot of pressure
to just execute people
um and one of the forgotten pieces of
the post-war history was the real debate
should we have these
war crimes trials at all the four
japanese men
on trial were ultimately given between
five and nine years
hard labor parody says shanghai set the
stage for better known trials that came
after
the tokyo and nuremberg war crimes
tribunals
which held high-ranking officials of the
japanese empire
and nazi germany accountable for their
actions
and he says it became the precedent for
laws that still govern
modern warfare the doolittle raid goes
from being an important military victory
to an important victory for american
values and ultimately succeeded in
not just making the the standard for
american allies around the world but
succeeded in making
international law the basic expectations
about human rights about fair trials
about the prohibition on torture
did not envy michelle's job going
through this massive amount of material
but he did a really nice job stringing
it
together it's always nice to hear about
a piece of history that you might not be
familiar with yeah and also just the
impact that he was just talking about at
the end there
that it's that lasting impact sometimes
doing the right thing
at the hardest time becomes the most
important thing we still try to live by
today